mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a four digit number divided by a two
digit number is equal to two digits and
a digit after the decimal point
some countries use the notation of a
comma in this video i will use a decimal
point
what could these numbers be
let me give a little bit more
information
these are the steps of a simple long
division
from this limited information you are to
solve for all of the blank spaces
it seems impossible but it's not
the problem was reported by sora news 24
with the headline can you solve this
crazy difficult super satisfying math
puzzle from a japanese middle schooler
they credit the twitter account at ati
underscore carbuncle and it was said to
have been created by a student who's 12
or 13 years old
i thank everyone who sent me the problem
including sagar shaylar nipoon aryan
michael rishov and at blackwolf howler
i highly encourage you give this problem
a try
it is difficult but it is super
satisfying to figure out
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we figure out this problem
suppose the divisor is the two-digit
number a b and the quotient is c d point
e
we'll approach the problem in four steps
we'll first deduce e is equal to five b
is even and a is equal to one
then we'll deduce that b is either 4 or
8 so a b is either 14 or 18.
then we'll determine a b is equal to 14
and cd point e is equal to 97.5
finally we'll solve for the remaining
blank spaces
let's get started
we'll actually approach this problem
from the very end
in the very end this column
is one decimal point after the original
four digit number
so it must be the result of carrying
down a zero
since the final result is zero we must
have a zero in both of the units column
now this final step is the result of
multiplying a b by e
this means a b e is a multiple of 10
which means b multiplied by e is a
two-digit multiple of 10.
naturally e cannot be equal to zero
because if the quotient was a whole
number we wouldn't need anything after
the decimal point
so what are the possibilities for b and
e
one case is that b is equal to zero and
then e could be any digit
the other possibilities will all involve
one factor of two and one factor of five
in order to get a multiple of ten
now it looks like we haven't really done
much because we still have a lot of
possibilities
but we're going to use one more
observation
consider the first step where we have a
b multiplied by c is equal to a three
digit number ending in six
this means b multiplied by c must end in
a six
therefore b cannot be equal to five
a number that ends in five will always
have multiples that end in five or zero
similarly b cannot be equal to zero
because multiples will then end in zero
and we need b multiplied by c to end in
six
we'll combine this with our list
since b cannot be equal to five we'll
eliminate all of these possibilities
since b cannot be equal to zero we'll
eliminate this possibility
so we're left with the following four
options
in all cases e is equal to five
we then have b is equal to 4 6 or 8.
we can deduce further
notice that in the very last step it's
the result of a b multiplied by 5.
so a b multiplied by 5 has to be a
2-digit multiple of 10.
the largest multiple that's 2 digits is
90. 90 divided by 5 is equal to 18.
this means a has to be less than or
equal to 1.
this means a is equal to one because we
exclude the case that a is equal to zero
that would be a leading digit like zero
eight
therefore a is equal to one
we'll now proceed to the second step
we're going to show that b is either
four or eight so a b is either 14 or 18.
to do that we'll consider the first step
we have one b multiplied by c is equal
to a three digit number ending in six
so we're going to consider multiplying
12 14 16 and 18 by a single digit c to
get a three digit number ending in six
we'll actually just work through these
possibilities they're not too many to
consider
of these three digit numbers there are
only two possibilities that end in six
it's either 14 by nine or 18 by seven
thus b is either four or eight
and if b is four c is 9 and if b is 8 c
is 7.
we'll ignore this for a moment and just
focus on b
from here we go to the next step and
determine that a b is equal to 14 and c
d e is equal to 97.5
we'll consider both cases of b is equal
to 4 and b is equal to 8.
if we have 8 a b is equal to 18 and we
have 4 a b is equal to 14.
so for a b is equal to 18 notice that we
need 18 by 5 in the final step which
will be equal to 90.
so the previous step must also be equal
to 90 to cancel out
we then have the following thing and
it's a little bit complicated so let me
go through it slowly
notice we have a three digit number
minus a two digit multiple of 18 equal
to nine
so
we need a three digit number minus a two
digit multiple of eighteen to be equal
to nine
what possibilities could we have for
this well we work through the
possibilities
the first possibility of 18 by 5 doesn't
work because 99 is a two-digit number
and we need a three-digit number
another possibility is 18 times 6 plus
9. this doesn't work because 108 is a
three-digit number so neither of these
cases could work
so we'll consider that a b cannot be
equal to 18.
we'll then go through a b is equal to
14.
in this case
14 multiplied by 5 is equal to 70. we
then have a 7 over here so in this step
we need a 3-digit number minus a 2-digit
multiple of 14 to be equal to 7 or a
2-digit multiple of 14 plus 7 is a
three-digit number we actually do get
something that works here 14 times 7
plus 7 is equal to 98 plus 7 which is
equal to 105.
thus b could be equal to 4 and d could
be equal to 7.
now recall if b is equal to 4 from
before we deduce that c has to be equal
to 9.
therefore b is equal to 4 d is equal to
7 and c is equal to 9.
we can then go to the final step and
solve for the remaining blank spaces
we can first recover the original number
14 times 97.5 is equal to 1365
so those are the original four digits
to get the final three digits we
subtract 126 from 136 to get 10.
we then carry down the 5 and we filled
the remaining blank spot
that's the answer to this puzzle and
it's the only answer what an amazing
problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
you